shaumbra chan works at a warehouse
picking orders from miles of shelves
this is his coworker Karla Wally it it's
a robot powered by artificial
intelligence and he isn't alone
doctors are beginning to rely on AI for
diagnosing disease machines are taking
the wheel from truck drivers and chefs
are handing their ladles to robotic line
cooks doesn't matter whether you're
working in a factory or sitting at a
desk or working in the service sector if
you're doing something that is
fundamentally routine and predictable
that job is ultimately going to be
threatened by a machine learning will
work ever be the same
where are we heading towards a jobless
future
[Music]
so in here this is where we assemble the
robots
here's your your future job is a robot
builder Melanie wise is the CEO of fetch
robotics her team builds autonomous
robots that use sensors cameras and
mapping algorithms to navigate
warehouses so instead of a picker
walking several hundreds of miles over
the course of a week they would give the
goods to the robot and the robot does
all that transportation and they save me
about couple hours in the day make my
job of it easier @rk logistics which
supplies high-tech companies with
semiconductor parts fetch robots have
become part of the workforce
it wasn't about trying to replace people
it was about trying to use the people
that we have the employees that we have
for the tasks that they are good at and
are interesting and that they want to be
doing we've not laid off one person
because of robots and in fact because
it's made us even more competitive we've
actually only been hiring even so
mounting evidence suggests that the risk
of robots replacing humans in the labor
force is real according to one study
about half our jobs are at high risk for
automation and it's not just manual
labor
it's also your white-collar things it's
this job's done by journalists and
radiologists and all kinds of other you
know professional people that often have
lots of Education historically new
technology has increased productivity
and created new jobs but this time could
be different the machines are moving
into that cognitive space they're
thinking they're they're learning
they're adapting they're doing things
that used to be uniquely human and
eventually we're going to see an
unprecedented disruption that kind of
disruption is what concerns workers like
Robert James yes it worries me because
of automation causes people to lose jobs
James is a forklift operator at the
carrier Factory in Indianapolis with a
manufacturer of furnaces and air
conditioners
he's also the vice president of their
local union they shop a well the
benefits are good so
this factory may be a good indicator of
where the manufacturing industry is
heading last February carriers president
told employees at the Indianapolis
factory that their jobs were moving
tomorrow a mess ago then in November the
company struck a deal with president
elect Trump to keep around 700 jobs at
the factory no we're not leaving but
those jobs still aren't safe here's what
United Technologies CEO Greg Hayes told
CNBC a few days later we're going to
make up 16 million dollar investment in
that Factory in Indianapolis to automate
right that ultimately means is there
will be fewer jobs I think that UTC will
attempt to automate every job that they
possibly can we are in some cases seeing
factories come back but of course what
happens is that the factories are then
almost entirely automated so the
production is here they're there they're
building something here but there are
very few jobs so what can we do if
machines take our jobs one potential
solution is something called a universal
basic income a universal basic income is
the idea of income unconditionally given
to everyone regardless of how much work
they do where they work where they live
it may sound unrealistic but something
like it has been in place for decades in
Alaska where every resident gets an
average of $1,000 a year thanks to oil
dividends what's radical about that is
it's money that Alaskans didn't work for
and they believe that they deserve
critics say that it will make people
lazy but Foster disagrees will people
work if they have Economic Security is a
very good question
I the science shows that people in fact
do work but the other thing we have to
ask ourselves is what constitutes work
there are people who have worked without
pay for a long time I think of parents I
think of caregivers and so I think the
thing that basic Economic Security would
allow is the kinds of work that people
want to do and they're passionate about
if this idea doesn't catch on there may
be other ways to prepare like retraining
programs or
taxes on companies that replace workers
with robots but one thing is clear
there's no going back the worst thing to
do is just to pretend that it's not
going to happen and sit there and do
nothing our challenge is to figure out a
way to adapt to this future where people
may be working less